what's the best way to get people to
read your script well you know those
platforms have kind of changed over time
there used to be different ways to do
that I mean I probably for me see I'm
I've always written with tor with an eye
toward directing so for me a script is
just a blueprint for a movie that hasn't
been made yet
that's all I've always seen it that way
even though I've done writing gigs you
know that brother you know four
different producers and movie didn't get
produced but you know put everything
into that but I've always written this
script just with you know with an eye to
we're getting it produced and so I would
just I don't know like I think you need
to know see nowadays it's so different
it's so different I mean there's there's
still the you know script shark and all
these different you know sites that
people go out I don't trust those things
I don't trust those sites I I feel like
they just take your money and then who
knows what happens with it you know I
think I've been the time the type of
person who I entered screenplay
competitions early on that's something I
could say I think it's good the inner
screenplay competitions I do believe
that I don't think there's anything
wrong with that
just don't go bankrupt doing it you know
I don't think don't spend your last dime
on it but I don't know I just I'm just
the type of person who I never really
entered a lot of things like that yeah
I'm just I'm just tell you I suppose
doesn't make great interview material
it's a lot of stopping and starting I'm
just I'm just being honest I mean like I
entered some screenplay competitions and
I placed in some of them too but those
things didn't get produced and then the
first screenwriting job I ever got
actually it was while I was on kiss the
girls I was walking around the set with
horror t-shirts on The Exorcist
Evil Dead and the craft service guy said
you have big horror fan and I said yeah
I'm a horror fan and and I made some
shorts and he said how about you rewrite
a script for me I'll pay you to rewrite
a script and this is the guy who's
literally picking up trash like he's got
the you know like the pointer you know a
picking up trash and he's like I got a
Horace
it needs a rewrite and I remember he
said to me we're talking we're
negotiating and I say he said well I
heard that Tarantino got $500 to rewrite
from dusk till dawn because that's what
happened with that that started as a
script by some effects artists who
wanted to make a movie and Tarantino got
involved and that's how the whole thing
started I don't know if that's how much
he got paid but anyway that's what this
guy said and I said he said $500 he said
how about if I give you what turn Tino
got to do that I said okay sure of
course I'll take that I'm thrilled I'm
22 years old and I'm 21 years old I'm
working on a movie and and I'm gonna do
a script rewrite on the side so probably
the reason I bring that up is you need
to be around film people you need to be
around people who want to make movies
everybody's got a movie they want to
make like amber another job I got this
is before I got anything produced
another screenwriting job I got was
something that I it was a script I
optioned that's what it was it was some
brothers it was like two twin brothers
and they were friends of some effects
artists whose shop I was working in at
the time just you know I was doing
effects work and they wanted to they
were looking for scripts that they could
act in just horror scripts whatever and
so I had this script I told my friend I
wrote a script and he said I'll show it
to these guys and he showed it to him
and they optioned it from me and I
remember they used to finish each
other's sentences on the phone ever like
it was like the Coen brothers you know
so those are my first to like paid
script things and it just came from
being around film people from being
really I think people who just sit at
home and they are in front of the
computer you're not gonna get anywhere
with that you can submit the script
Charcot you'll spend money you won't
make money you'll spend money and it's
not all about making money either
because somebody wants to make your
movie and you're gonna it's gonna get
off the ground that's that's great if
your first credit that's a that's you
made it you know what I mean but in
terms of like those are some of my
earliest experiences I don't know you
know I mean cool story that was in the
90s though right so it wasn't a night
there was I mean there's a stylist maybe
but all that stuff didn't exist and I
mean that was just as well because this
is we're fine I'm just telling you like
these were I had fun doing these things
like with the guy with the craft
services I mean I end up
I remember with him over to neo art and
logic which was neo they're making
movies with Miramax they're making
horror movies with Miramax so I was
sitting in their offices did that lead
anywhere no but it was just that was
cool to be sitting there you know and he
was honest and he paid me what'd he say
he was gonna pay me and I had the movie
didn't get me but so what you know it
was just a nice gig and I did the best I
could with it and you know and the thing
with the brothers didn't get made either
but the first thing that I wrote that
got produced was something I directed it
was a package deal I pitched scream
queen to the producer who I was working
as a PA I was working as a PA on this
movie and the producer was doing smaller
films even smaller than the one we were
making and he said hey do you have some
ideas for some stuff and and I pitched
him a few and screenplay was one and he
said that sounds good let's do that so
but that was a writing directing package
so once again I was on a set in the
desert we're in the Mojave Desert
sitting in the guy's car talking at
lunch and that was how the deal was made
Wow so they're all you know these things
are all bound up in being out there and
doing stuff they're not about being at
home and emailing and texting and stuff
but like you said it was 90s different
time and I know that there's these sites
out there and stuff the people I know
would rather people probably gotten
stuff from that too I'm not saying they
don't but that's just not my background
you look on Mandy if you took get a bit
more updated or whatever if you go on
Mandy and these sites people are looking
for scripts people are looking for
writers and I've gotten jobs that way
too I've gotten jobs completely out of
the clear blue from a guy looking for a
guy to do rewrites on his horror script
and I've gotten jobs like that too so
that's yeah that's one that was down the
desert this point it's at home in front
of my computer that's awesome the guy's
just picking this stuff up and I mean
yeah he was literally picking up trash
and I had these t-shirts on and Cary
Elwes was on that film too and he's like
oh man awesome sure like he loved my
Exorcist sure because I Linda Blair
throwing up on the shirt I had like
different horror t-shirts all I wore was
black t-shirts back then had Evil Dead
reanimate ER and
Exorcist so I just wear those every day
and I guess I became like the heart
known as the horror guy or something and
then the night I was playing my short
film I was really obnoxious they had a
TV and the craft services trailer and I
would play my short film in there any
chance I got
so people were you know trying to get
like some you know you know an almond
joy and they had to like watch part of
the movie while they're there
did they unless you play it at the place
where they had the curtains next nectars
no okay whatever they were they had no
interest in my short film over there
curious no they I got plenty of Crimea
currents you know and whatever granola
bars but but you weren't allowed to play
your short and they never played it was
just just an office you know and I
remember pulling up in a drawer there
was the SP file some coverage and I
pulled up in a drawer and I saw that the
coverage for seven pass oh not
interested this will not do well pass
and that's when you and that's good to
see things like that too because you see
that one person's past is another
person's huge success
you know if they take the the chance on
the project you never know I mean no one
knew seven would do as well as it did I
mean when that movie came out it was so
under there it was so under the radar
you know so it was interesting to see
these things like I saw ever seeing
scary movie before it was scream and
they probably passed on that one too
they answered they're passing on a lot
of stuff who was who was reading all
this uh well they were executives but
there they would I mean they had I don't
think they were farming it out to
readers they were just using the interns
as readers you know like the big
agencies have like well they used to
have before they downsize they used to
have readers so that was their job just
to read scripts but not really anymore
did they let you do that did you they
did I took scripts home with me and read
them yeah yeah I would I would they
would called the weekend read I remember
we'd meet like on a Thursday or Friday
or whatever and they would they give you
scripts and then you'd come in and uncle
Monday probably Monday or Tuesday and we
would all sit down it wasn't a lot of
people's like five people we'd said I
mean maybe two other interns and we just
located what you guys read what did you
think they wanted to know what we
thought which was pretty cool you know
so I was reading all different types of
movies - dramas period pieces you know
sci-fi stuff they were they were reading
all they were they had a lot of scripts
coming in you know were these younger
people they were have because did they
want to know the pulse of like the you
know I mean if they did they didn't let
on to that but there was me yeah all the
interns were the same age we're all in
like our early 20s you know so they and
the executives weren't like I mean they
probably work maybe 10 years older than
us or something like that you know but I
never know I mean I just you know we
just did that and that was calling
business as usual over there so but did
you realize you were part of this big
machine or it felt that felt like a big
machine
I mean paramount in scott-free both felt
like big machines to me they both felt
like there's this machine moving forward
and there isn't any particular person
driving it it's just going and that's
really how big studio movies are more
now more than ever I would say and
development and a lot of this stuff it's
it's very hard they almost thrive on a
lack of like one person being in charge
or one person taking the blame or you
know they specifically created that kind
of infrastructure so they didn't oh
nobody gets really you know nobody has
to take the fall for some that doesn't
work but I just prefer you know I think
from an early right early on I prefer
this sort of lower budget film sets
where the director is really directing
and the director doesn't show up nothing
happens and you know it's just more of a
creative environment where people can
contribute more and everybody gets to
contribute more actors everybody you
know so and I'm not saying these films
were like cake walks because there was
you know there were ups and downs on all
these movies but that I saw happen you
know sometimes I was shocked you know to
see people get overruled see directors
get overruled
you know things like that you you think
directors are gods when you're growing
up reading film magazines you think that
nobody tells it directly that's the last
word it's most like the old Hollywood
idea of that which I loathe even that
was really true but at least that's the
myth you know so to see that it was his
eye opening to be on set and see
someone's like power you service yeah to
see like on spoiler there were scenes
that were literally there was an actor
that had makeup on that he wanted to do
and the director want to do and one of
the producers found it offensive she was
like a devout Christian and she was
offended by the makeup and she made them
reshoot that scene there are other times
where one of the producers who was out
of town doing probably a film market or
something cuz he was more like a he was
he had directed stuff in the past that
it was really more of a money guy he
came down toward the end and decided he
wanted to direct the movie so there were
parts of that movie where the director
was sort of literally sidelined and that
other guy was calling action and this
type of stuff happens all the time but
for me seeing that it was it was
eye-opening yeah for sure
you